hi I'm not by the way hi nah I'm not hi
this video is gonna really make it seem
like I am but I'm not
I'm just creative no no no you know
you're like it's different now I hope
that your expectations are like the
final round of limbo competition very
low last night I really wanted to make
pad thai for some reason that had this
huge craving then I thought Chrissy
Teigan recipe for pad thai and I also
realized that I probably should leave my
house occasionally so into the grocery
store they didn't have all the
ingredients that she had in her recipe
so I improvised I put some hotdogs in
there and so I woke up this morning
thinking about how I haven't actually
cooked anything on here that isn't a
hello fresh recipe which we love you
hello fresh very much thank you for your
constant support what I used to do
before all that was make really dumb
food you know what I want to do that
again what do I want to cook and the
first thing I wanted to cook was
spaghetti because I have been craving
spaghetti constantly lately because it's
delicious all the time every time
forever i had spaghetti and meatballs
for breakfast on my birthday this year
and then I started thinking also it's
football season so there's all those
kinds of party football foods like wings
and why are winds the only thing you
think wing wings what if I do the good
old-fashion grace how big cooking method
bind to things that would normally go
together spaghetti and buffalo wings
I make buffalo D and then I thought how
do I make it portable and cute like
something you could have at a party so
what if I turn it into cups you follow
me I'm not high I swear I'm not hot just
creative and excited and disgusting so
today I'm gonna attempt to make buffalo
D cups this has probably been done
before but I have purposely not looked
up anything because if I fail I want to
fail on my own and if I succeed I don't
want to give anyone else anything credit
for it come on so my idea is pretty
basic it's that we're gonna make
spaghetti with buffalo sauce and then
we're gonna put some egg
and breadcrumbs into it and we're gonna
put it into some cupcake containers and
we're gonna bake it in the oven and
we're going to top it with some blue
cheese crumbles and that's it
theoretically this could be amazing
realistically this will probably not be
amazing but hey we're having fun first
thing we're gonna do is move quicker
than our thoughts can tell us that we
shouldn't be doing this I think we know
he's gonna cook spaghetti the way you
cook spaghetti you boil some water you
put the plastic in and then the plastic
turns into edible little worm you can
put in your body I'm already doing
cooking salt water this is where I
forget that cooking spaghetti is long
down dammit it's not much else that we
can work on currently because that's our
big old base hmmm oh this is our first
speed bump yeah it's like sports you
know football I just remembered that I
am actually allergic to small talk so
this is how you make spaghetti okay
spaghetti is in cooking we're gonna let
that boil for like ten minutes what is
burning
something's mildly burning this is not a
song it is good wait he's actually
perfect do you see that the pasta was
leaning up against the top cured too
long and it burnt that's gonna add some
texture gonna let that boil and come
back because we both know at this point
I don't like filling up that's basically
why I had the wet dream daddy's ready
we're gonna do what my anxiety does to
my mental health strain it
Ron's next steps and this is where my
lack of planning really comes into play
like your thoughts
there's not many of them - instead of
spaghetti sauce I want to use this
buffalo sauce I think I want to put just
this straight on the pasta as is so hard
educators so yeah we're just gonna pour
this
[Music]
now we mix it up here's where my actual
real thinking comes into my thinking I
want to bake them in the oven to make
these little cups but I want to put egg
and bread crumbs in it because that's
like what you put in meatballs to like
keep it together to congeal it but I
don't want the eggs to go in a super hot
spaghetti exam I think it's gonna just
like scramble the eggs right I feel like
I'm on the great british bacon show and
i'm trying to figure out the technical
challenge oh my god and you gave me this
technical challenge myself you know what
I think I want to put it in like the
freezer to let it cool down go chill out
and you need to cool your temperature
down you know we don't need to talk well
okay we're back this has been taking way
longer than I thought it would it's
still a little warm but I don't want to
fully cool it down because I'm impatient
and I think in my clump together here's
what we're gonna do I'm out of breath
because I'm excited about next steps
I planned us to add a few eggs in here
maybe some breadcrumbs depending on how
moist it is you can't have Buffalo style
without bleu cheese so these blue cheese
crumbles that I'm debating whether to
put them in the mix or to sprinkle them
on top also I cooked up some delicious
frozen buffalo chicken that I was gonna
maybe chop up and put in a couple of
these just to see if it works we'll play
it by ear
first of all let's add the eggs I don't
know how many I should add I'm gonna
start with three and go from there I'm
gonna add one more egg I don't want to
make a borderline quiche but I don't
want to make a piece of Shh this looks
like a sloppy gooey thing I guess I've
got some bread crumbs this might be
counterintuitive what is it a little bit
I'm crazy you guys
I'm gonna add one more egg I'm gonna mix
some blue cheese crumbles into this and
then I'm gonna put it in the cupcake
tank you know I talk a lot in therapy
about my indecisiveness so you won't
regret this you're making a choice and
that's a beautiful thing that's right
but done
[Music]
sorry gwyneth paltrow
we got goo yeah we're gonna put this in
the oven for an indeterminate amount of
time and that's when I realized that it
wasn't even a wet dream it was actually
like real life that was happening there
done I don't know if they're done I've
had these in there for like 25 minutes
now because I did I broke down and I
googled like how long does quiche take
to cook in an oven and it takes between
like 20 and 30 minutes and these started
to brown on top and also I don't think
they're gonna work but hey okay so so
mr. Fudd I haven't thought out do I need
to let these cool down now I'm gonna let
them cool down for like ten minutes and
then we'll see if we can like take them
out alright to be expected I put these
in the refrigerator for like five
minutes to cool down because I'm you
know I've been here too long let's see
what happens let's try and take them out
of these little cake molds this genius
idea it came to fruition oh my god it
worked
I don't freak out because I want to
remain humble about my abilities but I'm
a genius look at that ah there we go
Cheers uh I don't know if I have low
standards or if I'm real hungry but this
is delicious
I did a Pinterest thing I'm sure this is
not a unique idea to blame that on not
doing my research but for my bubble of
brain that I live in right now without
wanting to resource the outside world I
made a thing that I'm so proud of
yeah for real fun I cannot believe this
work I'm gonna take some Beauty shots of
thing you like this video give it a
thumbs up don't forget to subscribe to
this YouTube channel I'm making videos
you know also don't forget to listen
weekly to this make it weird podcast the
favorite hearten I do and not too deep
comes out every Monday also made me
heart and I are doing this make it weird
live and Irvine the link for tickets is
in description box below
I've literally my body it's like having
a hard time other than that I don't know
also just so you know off camera I mixed
all the rest of the pasta that was left
over together with more eggs and I put
it in the oven and it's cooking so thank
God this worked out oh I got a baby
bacon in there holy [ __ ] this work this
isn't crap oh my god okay I'm very happy